the tangent upon a tangent upon a
tangent how do you equate a compelling
Quest because there's all kinds of
personalities of humans that play these
games right because I like the grind
well there's look there's there's
multiple flavors of a compelling quest
uh
you know some of them have very good
upfront storytelling you just like the
story and the NPC that's giving you this
task and then uh you'll go through a
more handcrafted experience that
the designers have done a really really
good job on the space it has some some
twister surprise in the middle and then
the ending has some
you know multiple options that the
player feels like they had they got to
do something they made an interesting
choice but the best ones for me are
actually were
all of that was far more open-ended the
how I am going to accomplish this task
is
completely up to me and I'm gonna find
some ingenious solution
a silly that this was like this sounds
very basic it's going to sound quite
cliche and silly go find me five danger
cards or whatever like find me X of
something that's hard to get
that's a very simple set you can give a
simple story set up for that
and we're not telling the player where
to get those and I think now where could
I get those
and I've actually find those
to be just as rewarding as the really
handcrafted well done a little bit more
linear with an interesting choice at the
end if those objects
are in the world in some you know
believable way that there's usually some
challenge at getting getting them